I'll try saying loud things because I'm a loud person. Stop. Stop laughing. It's just great because I'm the one that gets to cut this stuff. And you know I'm going to put in saying loud things. Saying loud things. Oh, that's unfortunate because that would have been like perfect research for this episode, right? Yeah, yeah.
I'll try saying loud things because I'm a loud person. Stop. Stop laughing. It's just great because I'm the one that gets to cut this stuff. And you know I'm going to put in saying loud things. Saying loud things. Oh, that's unfortunate because that would have been like perfect research for this episode, right? Yeah, yeah.|||我会试着大声说话，因为我本来就是一个嗓门很大的人。住手。别笑了。这太棒了，因为剪辑这些内容的人是我。而且你知道我一定会把大声说话这部分剪进去的。大声说话。噢，那可真遗憾，因为那对这一期节目来说简直是完美的调研资料，对吧？对，对。
But that's the thing. It's like it's one search away. Yeah, I found it. I found it. I'm good at searching. I'm good at searching. Oh, yeah, yeah. This is it. Exactly, yeah, but that's the thing. It's like it's one search away. Yeah, I found it. I found it. I'm good at searching. I'm good at searching. Oh, yeah, yeah. This is it. Exactly, yeah. And there are two, I recall, yeah, there's two, recorded on November 28th, 2020. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we're going to be talking about what our favorite data structures are. Hey, Matt, how's it going?
But that's the thing. It's like it's one search away. Yeah, I found it. I found it. I'm good at searching. I'm good at searching. Oh, yeah, yeah. This is it. Exactly, yeah, but that's the thing. It's like it's one search away. Yeah, I found it. I found it. I'm good at searching. I'm good at searching. Oh, yeah, yeah. This is it. Exactly, yeah. And there are two, I recall, yeah, there's two, recorded on November 28th, 2020. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we're going to be talking about what our favorite data structures are. Hey, Matt, how's it going?|||但关键就在这里。这就好像只要搜一下就能找到一样。对，我找到了。我找到了。我很擅长搜索。我很擅长搜索。哦，对，对。就是这个。没错，对，但关键就在这里。这就好像只要搜一下就能找到一样。对，我找到了。我找到了。我很擅长搜索。我很擅长搜索。哦，对，对。就是这个。没错，对。据我回忆，有两个，对，有两个，录制于2020年11月28日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）将讨论我们最喜欢的数据结构是什么。嘿，马特（Matt），最近怎么样？
It's pretty good, how are you doing? I'm enjoying the one true American Thanksgiving down here while you Canadian heathens are doing your thing. We had the real Thanksgiving a month ago, so I don't know what you're talking about. You know that there's more people in the state that I live in than in your entire country? That, is that true? Yeah, like, I think there's, like, 35 million Canadians and there, British Columbia, our most western province, is larger than the combined geography of your three coastal western states, California, Oregon, and Washington. So you win some, you lose some. I'm not surprised.
It's pretty good, how are you doing? I'm enjoying the one true American Thanksgiving down here while you Canadian heathens are doing your thing. We had the real Thanksgiving a month ago, so I don't know what you're talking about. You know that there's more people in the state that I live in than in your entire country? That, is that true? Yeah, like, I think there's, like, 35 million Canadians and there, British Columbia, our most western province, is larger than the combined geography of your three coastal western states, California, Oregon, and Washington. So you win some, you lose some. I'm not surprised.|||挺好的，你怎么样？我在这里享受着正宗的美国感恩节，而你们这些加拿大异教徒则在过你们的节。我们一个月前就已经过过真正的感恩节了，所以我不知道你在说什么。你知道我住的这个州的人口比你们整个国家的人口还要多吗？真的吗？对，比如说，我觉得大概有3500万加拿大人，而且，不列颠哥伦比亚省——我们最西边的省份，面积比你们西海岸三个州（加利福尼亚州、俄勒冈州和华盛顿州）的地理面积加起来还要大。所以有得必有失吧。我一点也不觉得意外。
I actually really like British Columbia My mom My stepdad and I Went up to visit Like Victoria Island Vancouver Island Yes, Vancouver Island Vancouver Victoria Victoria is the name of the capital
I actually really like British Columbia My mom My stepdad and I Went up to visit Like Victoria Island Vancouver Island Yes, Vancouver Island Vancouver Victoria Victoria is the name of the capital|||我其实非常喜欢不列颠哥伦比亚省。我妈妈、我继父和我曾去参观过，比如维多利亚岛、温哥华岛……对，温哥华岛。温哥华、维多利亚。维多利亚是首府的名字。
That's on Vancouver Island, is that right? Yes, that is true yeah yeah and it was like we actually we did it in October so and it was like rainy and dreary and kind of a little bit like depressing weather but I had a nice time I really liked it and I really like Seattle um I really like that whole that whole vicinity yeah Seattle reminds me of uh reminds me of New England where I grew up. Yeah, I studied in Vancouver. Oh, you did? That's right.
That's on Vancouver Island, is that right? Yes, that is true yeah yeah and it was like we actually we did it in October so and it was like rainy and dreary and kind of a little bit like depressing weather but I had a nice time I really liked it and I really like Seattle um I really like that whole that whole vicinity yeah Seattle reminds me of uh reminds me of New England where I grew up. Yeah, I studied in Vancouver. Oh, you did? That's right.|||那是维多利亚岛上的，对吧？是的，没错，对，对。而且我们其实是在十月份去的，所以当时下着雨，阴沉沉的，天气有点让人郁闷，但我过得很开心，我真的很喜欢那里。而且我很喜欢西雅图，嗯，我非常喜欢那一整片区域。西雅图让我想起……让我想起我长大的新英格兰地区。对，我在温哥华上过学。哦，是吗？没错。
It is a very, very beautiful... Yeah, for those that, I guess, because we're just chatting now, but I currently live in Toronto. I was in the Bay Area, which is where Bryce and I met for just over a year, but I grew up in British Columbia in the middle of nowhere and then studied in Vancouver, which is, yeah. What was the name of your town? You once told me it was the equivalent of the New Jersey of Canada. It was like the armpit of Canada. So the armpit of Canada, that's a joke that refers to Hamilton, which is in Ontario.
It is a very, very beautiful... Yeah, for those that, I guess, because we're just chatting now, but I currently live in Toronto. I was in the Bay Area, which is where Bryce and I met for just over a year, but I grew up in British Columbia in the middle of nowhere and then studied in Vancouver, which is, yeah. What was the name of your town? You once told me it was the equivalent of the New Jersey of Canada. It was like the armpit of Canada. So the armpit of Canada, that's a joke that refers to Hamilton, which is in Ontario.|||那是一个非常非常美丽的……对，对于那些……我想，因为我们现在只是在闲聊，但我目前住在多伦多。我曾在湾区待了一年多，也就是我和布莱斯相遇的地方，但我是在不列颠哥伦比亚省一个偏僻的小地方长大的，后来在温哥华求学，所以，对。你们那个镇叫什么名字？你曾经告诉我，它相当于加拿大的新泽西州。它就像是加拿大的腋下。所以，“加拿大的腋下”，这是一个用来指代安大略省汉密尔顿（Hamilton）的笑话。
Which is where you currently live. No, well, yeah, I live in Hamilton, which is in Ontario. Which is where you currently live. Yeah, I live in Ontario, but not in Hamilton. Hamilton has got its redeeming qualities, though. It's also known as the waterfall capital of Canada because it's got a lot of waterfalls. But my hometown is, I'm sure most of the listeners have no idea where this is, but it's a small city called Prince George, which which yeah it's uh it's a city of trees and trucks a lot of a lot of trees and a lot of trucks yeah so i think today we were supposed to talk about our favorite data structures right yes the follow-up we ended up having to do two episodes on
Which is where you currently live. No, well, yeah, I live in Hamilton, which is in Ontario. Which is where you currently live. Yeah, I live in Ontario, but not in Hamilton. Hamilton has got its redeeming qualities, though. It's also known as the waterfall capital of Canada because it's got a lot of waterfalls. But my hometown is, I'm sure most of the listeners have no idea where this is, but it's a small city called Prince George, which which yeah it's uh it's a city of trees and trucks a lot of a lot of trees and a lot of trucks yeah so i think today we were supposed to talk about our favorite data structures right yes the follow-up we ended up having to do two episodes on|||也就是你目前居住的地方。不，好吧，对，我住在安大略省的汉密尔顿。也就是你目前居住的地方。对，我住在安大略省，但不住在汉密尔顿。不过汉密尔顿也有它的可取之处。它也被称为加拿大的瀑布之都，因为那里有很多瀑布。但我的家乡——我相信绝大多数听众都不知道这是哪里——是一个叫乔治王子城（Prince George）的小城市，那是一个……对，那是一个到处都是树木和卡车的城市，有很多很多的树和很多很多的卡车。对，所以我想我们今天本该讨论我们最喜欢的数据结构，对吧？是的，作为后续，我们最终不得不录制两期节目来讨论……
our our favorite algorithms because apparently we can't stay on topic and we start topics and don't finish them um but the follow-up to that is what is uh each of our respective favorite data structures or data i have a feeling that this is going to end up taking two episodes too potentially uh who's going first are you going well so i first? I think first we should talk about the word data structure. So a couple months ago, we were creating this new library at NVIDIA, which is now called KU Collections. And we were trying to figure out what to name this library. It was a library of containers or or data structures or collections whatever your term is for it um and we we wanted to pick a name that would be a good name and like we uh we couldn't
our our favorite algorithms because apparently we can't stay on topic and we start topics and don't finish them um but the follow-up to that is what is uh each of our respective favorite data structures or data i have a feeling that this is going to end up taking two episodes too potentially uh who's going first are you going well so i first? I think first we should talk about the word data structure. So a couple months ago, we were creating this new library at NVIDIA, which is now called KU Collections. And we were trying to figure out what to name this library. It was a library of containers or or data structures or collections whatever your term is for it um and we we wanted to pick a name that would be a good name and like we uh we couldn't|||我们最喜欢的算法，因为显然我们无法专注在一个话题上，总是开启新话题却又无法完结。不过这期节目的后续内容是，我们各自最喜欢的数据结构（或数据）是什么。我有种预感，这可能最终也会耗费两期节目。呃，谁先开始？你先来吗？好吧，那我先来？我觉得我们首先应该讨论一下“数据结构”这个词。所以几个月前，我们在英伟达（NVIDIA）创建了一个新库，现在叫KU Collections。我们当时在想该给这个库起什么名字。这是一个关于容器、数据结构或集合的库——无论你用哪个词来称呼它——我们想挑一个好名字，而且我们呃……不能……
call it koo containers because that would be too confusing and ambiguous with um you know like docker and kubernetes etc um like there's already like an nvidia docker project which is you know, like Docker and Kubernetes, et cetera. Like there's already like an NVIDIA Docker project, which is, you know, not that far away from like maybe, sorry, there's already an NVIDIA container project, which is not that far away from a KU collections or KU containers project. And so we wanted something that was like, you know, not going to be ambiguous with containerization.
call it koo containers because that would be too confusing and ambiguous with um you know like docker and kubernetes etc um like there's already like an nvidia docker project which is you know, like Docker and Kubernetes, et cetera. Like there's already like an NVIDIA Docker project, which is, you know, not that far away from like maybe, sorry, there's already an NVIDIA container project, which is not that far away from a KU collections or KU containers project. And so we wanted something that was like, you know, not going to be ambiguous with containerization.|||把它叫做ku containers，因为这会让人感到困惑，并且与诸如Docker和Kubernetes等技术产生歧义，比如已经有一个NVIDIA Docker项目，你知道的，就像Docker和Kubernetes等等。就像已经有一个NVIDIA Docker项目一样，你知道的，这和……抱歉，已经有一个NVIDIA容器（container）项目了，这与KU collections或KU containers项目相距不远。所以我们想要一个不会与容器化（containerization）产生歧义的名字。
And so we asked you to do some research on what languages call data structures. And you came up, you looked at, I think, 12 or 15 languages. And it seems like most languages call them collections so like java python kotlin only c++ and ocaml call them containers and only racket and closure call them data structures and i'm sure there's other languages that weren't in your in the set that you researched but it seems like collections is the the most popular term and that's why, but it seems like collections is the most popular term, and that's why we called our library KU Collections. But to me, there's always been a different distinction
And so we asked you to do some research on what languages call data structures. And you came up, you looked at, I think, 12 or 15 languages. And it seems like most languages call them collections so like java python kotlin only c++ and ocaml call them containers and only racket and closure call them data structures and i'm sure there's other languages that weren't in your in the set that you researched but it seems like collections is the the most popular term and that's why, but it seems like collections is the most popular term, and that's why we called our library KU Collections. But to me, there's always been a different distinction|||于是我们让你做了一些调研，看看各种编程语言是如何称呼数据结构的。你查阅了大概12到15种语言。似乎大多数语言都称它们为“collections”（集合），比如Java、Python、Kotlin；只有C++和OCaml称它们为“containers”（容器）；只有Racket和Clojure称它们为“data structures”（数据结构）。我确信还有其他语言没有包含在你调研的集合中，但“collections”似乎是最受欢迎的术语，这就是为什么……不过“collections”似乎是最受欢迎的术语，所以我们把我们的库命名为KU Collections。但在我看来，这两者之间一直存在着一种不同的区别……
between these terms. It's like, sorry, to me, there's always been a distinction between these terms, that they're not just the same thing. Like mentally my model is that data structure refers to a particular implementation strategy, like a particular way of implementing some sort of container. Whereas container refers to an abstract interface that has,
between these terms. It's like, sorry, to me, there's always been a distinction between these terms, that they're not just the same thing. Like mentally my model is that data structure refers to a particular implementation strategy, like a particular way of implementing some sort of container. Whereas container refers to an abstract interface that has,|||在这些术语之间。就像是……抱歉，在我看来，这些术语之间一直存在着一种区别，它们并不是完全相同的概念。比如在我的心理模型中，数据结构指的是一种特定的实现策略，比如实现某种容器的特定方式。而容器则指的是一个抽象接口，它具有……
you know, certain guarantees. And maybe this is a very C++-y way of looking at things. But like as an example, I think of std colon colon map as being a container. It's like that defines an interface for something. Whereas the way that you might implement a std colon colon map is with a red black tree, which is a particular data structure. And this mindset, I think, is more useful if you consider things like the container adapters in C++, like std stack, where std stack, you can plug in multiple different template parameters to change how it's implemented. And then it exposes out this container interface. So that's always been the distinction for me, that a container is about the interface it exposes,
you know, certain guarantees. And maybe this is a very C++-y way of looking at things. But like as an example, I think of std colon colon map as being a container. It's like that defines an interface for something. Whereas the way that you might implement a std colon colon map is with a red black tree, which is a particular data structure. And this mindset, I think, is more useful if you consider things like the container adapters in C++, like std stack, where std stack, you can plug in multiple different template parameters to change how it's implemented. And then it exposes out this container interface. So that's always been the distinction for me, that a container is about the interface it exposes,|||你知道的，某些保证。也许这是一种非常C++化的看待问题的方式。但举个例子，我认为`std::map`就是一个容器。它定义了某种东西的接口。而你实现`std::map`的方式可能是通过红黑树，这是一种特定的数据结构。这种思维方式，我认为在考虑C++中的容器适配器（比如`std::stack`）时会更有用。对于`std::stack`，你可以传入多个不同的模板参数来改变它的实现方式。然后它会暴露出这个容器接口。所以对我来说，两者的区别一直在于：容器关乎它所暴露的接口，
whereas data structure is the term for the actual implementation of it. And collections is just never a term that I've ever used, so I've never really thought about it. But I guess that term seems to me like it's more closely, it just seems like an analogy for containers, not an analogy for the meaning of data structure that I just defined. Yeah, I think that's,
whereas data structure is the term for the actual implementation of it. And collections is just never a term that I've ever used, so I've never really thought about it. But I guess that term seems to me like it's more closely, it just seems like an analogy for containers, not an analogy for the meaning of data structure that I just defined. Yeah, I think that's,|||而数据结构则是其实际实现的术语。至于collections这个词，我从来没用过，所以我也没怎么去想过它。但我想这个词在我看来更接近于……它只是容器的一个类比，而不是我刚才定义的数据结构的含义的类比。是的，我觉得……
I did not until now have that mental model, but that makes complete sense to me. And for those of our listeners that aren't C++ developers, the red-black-tree data structure that Bryce mentioned is exactly, I think, how most of the standard libraries implement std map. And if you do have done any C++ development,
I did not until now have that mental model, but that makes complete sense to me. And for those of our listeners that aren't C++ developers, the red-black-tree data structure that Bryce mentioned is exactly, I think, how most of the standard libraries implement std map. And if you do have done any C++ development,|||我直到刚才才拥有这种心理模型，但这对我来说完全说得通。对于那些不是C++开发者的听众，布莱斯提到的红黑树数据结构，我认为正是大多数标准库实现`std::map`的方式。如果你做过任何C++开发，
you might have seen when you run into template errors every once in a while, there's like underscore, underscore, RB, colon, colon, and the RB in that case stands for the red-black-tree. But it doesn't need to be implemented that way, so that I think makes complete sense. Yeah. Can you think of other ways that you can implement std map? I know that most of the standard libraries do it with a red-black tree, but I think there are other ways that you could do it, right?
you might have seen when you run into template errors every once in a while, there's like underscore, underscore, RB, colon, colon, and the RB in that case stands for the red-black-tree. But it doesn't need to be implemented that way, so that I think makes complete sense. Yeah. Can you think of other ways that you can implement std map? I know that most of the standard libraries do it with a red-black tree, but I think there are other ways that you could do it, right?|||你可能偶尔会遇到模板错误，里面会出现像下划线、下划线、RB、冒号、冒号之类的东西，这里的RB代表的就是红黑树（red-black-tree）。但它不一定非要以这种方式实现，所以我觉得这完全说得通。是的。你能想到实现`std::map`的其他方法吗？我知道大多数标准库都是用红黑树来实现的，但我认为还有其他方法可以做到这一点，对吧？
I think any kind of balancing tree that says they're element-sorted, right? There's a bunch of them, but I... Yeah, I think that's right. I never took that course in school. I only have a math degree, and as we've established in previous episodes, I was a very bad student, so... But yeah, I think any data structure that is sort of self-balancing, or doesn't even need to be self-balancing, as long as the elements stay sorted. And I guess std map does make guarantees about the time complexity on operations.
I think any kind of balancing tree that says they're element-sorted, right? There's a bunch of them, but I... Yeah, I think that's right. I never took that course in school. I only have a math degree, and as we've established in previous episodes, I was a very bad student, so... But yeah, I think any data structure that is sort of self-balancing, or doesn't even need to be self-balancing, as long as the elements stay sorted. And I guess std map does make guarantees about the time complexity on operations.|||我认为任何保证元素排序的平衡树都可以，对吧？这类树有很多，但我……对，我觉得是这样的。我在学校里从来没修过那门课。我只有一个数学学位，正如我们在之前的节目中所提到的，我是一个非常差劲的学生，所以……不过是的，我认为任何某种程度上自平衡的（甚至不需要自平衡，只要元素保持排序即可）数据结构都可以。而且我想`std::map`确实对操作的时间复杂度做出了保证。
So I guess you can't actually, if you want to be standard compliant, you can't just use any data structure. You have to use ones that adhere to the complexity guarantees that the standard specifies. But other than that, yeah, there's a bunch of options, I'm sure. Well, and that gets into an interesting notion from C++ world, which is this idea that a concept or an interface isn't just about syntax, but it's also about semantics. You could have something that provides all of the operations that StoodMap does and even does the same thing in all the cases as what StoodMap would do, but if it has a different complexity um for some of the operations um
So I guess you can't actually, if you want to be standard compliant, you can't just use any data structure. You have to use ones that adhere to the complexity guarantees that the standard specifies. But other than that, yeah, there's a bunch of options, I'm sure. Well, and that gets into an interesting notion from C++ world, which is this idea that a concept or an interface isn't just about syntax, but it's also about semantics. You could have something that provides all of the operations that StoodMap does and even does the same thing in all the cases as what StoodMap would do, but if it has a different complexity um for some of the operations um|||所以我想你实际上不能……如果你想符合标准，你就不能随意使用任何数据结构。你必须使用符合标准指定的时间复杂度保证的数据结构。但除此之外，是的，肯定还有一堆可选方案。嗯，这就引出了C++世界中的一个有趣概念，即概念（concept）或接口不仅仅关乎语法，还关乎语义。你可能会有这样一种实现，它提供了`std::map`所有的操作，甚至在所有情况下做的事情都和`std::map`一样，但如果它在某些操作上有不同的复杂度……
we might say that it doesn't satisfy this you know the the concepts that std map satisfies because those concepts have certain complexity requirements associated with them because uh concepts have uh have uh semantic requirements as well. Yeah. And while you were saying that, I actually did think of, so I'm not actually sure if you can swap out this data structure for the Red Black Tree that's currently used. But even if it doesn't work, it refers to a great talk that I saw.
we might say that it doesn't satisfy this you know the the concepts that std map satisfies because those concepts have certain complexity requirements associated with them because uh concepts have uh have uh semantic requirements as well. Yeah. And while you were saying that, I actually did think of, so I'm not actually sure if you can swap out this data structure for the Red Black Tree that's currently used. But even if it doesn't work, it refers to a great talk that I saw.|||我们可能会说它不满足……你知道的，`std::map`所满足的概念，因为这些概念具有与其关联的特定复杂度要求，因为呃，概念也具有呃……语义要求。是的。当你在说这个的时候，我其实想到了……我其实不太确定你是否能用这个数据结构替换当前使用的红黑树。但即使行不通，这也让我联想到了我看到过的一场精彩演讲。
I believe it was at the 2019 meeting C++, or sorry, the 2019 Codive conference in Wroclaw, Poland. I could get this wrong, but I'm almost positive it was Bjorn Fowler that gave a talk on sort of things that I wish I had have known. a single example that is really inefficient and progressively like modifies things about it and switches the structured data structure that he's using. And ultimately, he ends up with something that's implementing a B tree, which is I think, similar to a red black tree, the difference being that it takes advantage of, you know, adjacent elements stored in memory so that you can have better cache coherency. And it's a fantastic talk. So even if you can't use a B-tree, I'll put it in the show notes and everyone should go
I believe it was at the 2019 meeting C++, or sorry, the 2019 Codive conference in Wroclaw, Poland. I could get this wrong, but I'm almost positive it was Bjorn Fowler that gave a talk on sort of things that I wish I had have known. a single example that is really inefficient and progressively like modifies things about it and switches the structured data structure that he's using. And ultimately, he ends up with something that's implementing a B tree, which is I think, similar to a red black tree, the difference being that it takes advantage of, you know, adjacent elements stored in memory so that you can have better cache coherency. And it's a fantastic talk. So even if you can't use a B-tree, I'll put it in the show notes and everyone should go|||我相信那是在2019年的Meeting C++会议上，或者抱歉，是2019年在波兰弗罗茨瓦夫举行的Codive会议上。我可能会记错，但我几乎可以肯定那是比约恩·法勒（Bjorn Fahler）的一场演讲，主题是“我希望自己早就知道的事”。他举了一个非常低效的单一例子，并逐步修改其中的内容，切换了他所使用的数据结构。最终，他实现了一个B树（B-tree），我认为它类似于红黑树，不同之处在于它利用了内存中存储的相邻元素，从而能获得更好的缓存一致性（cache coherency）。那是一场非常棒的演讲。所以即使你不能使用B树，我也会把它放在节目简介里，每个人都应该去……
watch it, even if you're not a C++ dev. Cool. Okay, so back to our question. What is your favorite data structure? Am I going first? Yeah, you're going first. A quote came to mind by a prolific individual from sort of the history of computer science, Alan J. Perlis. For those of you that don't know, he was the first recipient of the Turing Award in 1966. And he's famous for sort of a number of reasons, but one of them that a lot of people know is that he has this sort of collection of quotes called
watch it, even if you're not a C++ dev. Cool. Okay, so back to our question. What is your favorite data structure? Am I going first? Yeah, you're going first. A quote came to mind by a prolific individual from sort of the history of computer science, Alan J. Perlis. For those of you that don't know, he was the first recipient of the Turing Award in 1966. And he's famous for sort of a number of reasons, but one of them that a lot of people know is that he has this sort of collection of quotes called|||看一看，即使你不是C++开发者。太好了。好的，那么回到我们的问题。你最喜欢的数据结构是什么？我先来吗？对，你先来。我的脑海中浮现出计算机科学史上的一位多产人物艾伦·J·佩利（Alan J. Perlis）说过的一句话。对于那些不知道的人，他是1966年第一届图灵奖得主。他出名有很多原因，但其中一个广为人知的原因是，他有一组被称为……的名言集。
epigrams on programming. And one of those quotes is the following. It's better to have 100 functions operate on one data structure than 10 functions operate on 10 data structures. And this quote is actually what I care more about than the particular data structure. And so this leads me to sort of my favorite data structure in C++, or I guess if this is the case, it's more of a container, not a data structure, but it's Stood Vector, partially because, you know, of when Chandler said, you know,
epigrams on programming. And one of those quotes is the following. It's better to have 100 functions operate on one data structure than 10 functions operate on 10 data structures. And this quote is actually what I care more about than the particular data structure. And so this leads me to sort of my favorite data structure in C++, or I guess if this is the case, it's more of a container, not a data structure, but it's Stood Vector, partially because, you know, of when Chandler said, you know,|||《编程警句》（Epigrams on Programming）。其中有一句是这样的：与其让10个函数操作10个数据结构，不如让100个函数操作1个数据结构。其实比起某个特定数据结构本身，这句话才是我更在乎的。这就引导我找到了我在C++中最喜欢的数据结构——或者如果按刚才的说法，它更应该算是一个容器，而不是数据结构——那就是`std::vector`。部分原因是因为，你知道的，正如钱德勒（Chandler）曾经说过……
always reach for Stood Vector, basically half the time, it's going to be more efficient than whatever data structure you're reaching for, unless if it's like a niche case. And I think Tony Van Eerd, another individual in the C++ community, he also said like anytime you are not using a std vector, you should add a comment and say why, because std vector is so versatile. But yeah, it's my favorite data structure, mostly just because it's got, you know, constant time complexity for most things. And then insertion is amortized constant, which is fantastic. And when you combine it with that quote,
always reach for Stood Vector, basically half the time, it's going to be more efficient than whatever data structure you're reaching for, unless if it's like a niche case. And I think Tony Van Eerd, another individual in the C++ community, he also said like anytime you are not using a std vector, you should add a comment and say why, because std vector is so versatile. But yeah, it's my favorite data structure, mostly just because it's got, you know, constant time complexity for most things. And then insertion is amortized constant, which is fantastic. And when you combine it with that quote,|||总归去寻找`std::vector`，基本上有一半的时间，它都会比你费心去找的任何其他数据结构都要高效，除非遇到非常小众的情况。我认为C++社区的另一个人托尼·范·埃尔德（Tony Van Eerd）也说过，任何时候当你没有使用`std::vector`时，你都应该加上一条注释说明原因，因为`std::vector`实在是太全能了。不过是的，它是我最喜欢的数据结构，主要就是因为它……你知道的，对于大多数事情来说，它具有常数时间复杂度。而且插入操作是分摊常数时间复杂度（amortized constant），这太棒了。当你把它与那句名言结合起来时……
it's even more than just like having 100 functions, aka our STL algorithms that can work on it. We almost have in C++ like 100 functions slash algorithms that operate on 10 data structures. So like in the quote, it's 100 on one or 10 on 10, when this sort of is implicitly referring to something known as like the m times n versus the m plus n problem, where due to the fact that we have inner iterators as this sort of layer between our algorithms and our data structures. They're generic, and so a lot of the algorithms work on different containers or data structures,
it's even more than just like having 100 functions, aka our STL algorithms that can work on it. We almost have in C++ like 100 functions slash algorithms that operate on 10 data structures. So like in the quote, it's 100 on one or 10 on 10, when this sort of is implicitly referring to something known as like the m times n versus the m plus n problem, where due to the fact that we have inner iterators as this sort of layer between our algorithms and our data structures. They're generic, and so a lot of the algorithms work on different containers or data structures,|||这甚至不仅仅是拥有100个函数（也就是我们的STL算法）来处理它那么简单。在C++中，我们几乎有100个函数/算法可以操作10个数据结构。所以在引用中，那是“100个操作1个”或“10个操作10个”，而这隐式地指代了被称为“m乘以n”与“m加上 n”的问题——由于我们在算法和数据结构之间拥有迭代器（iterators）作为这样一层抽象。它们是通用的，因此许多算法可以适用于不同的容器或数据结构……
if you will, because of the iterators. So we almost have like 100 operating on 10, and of those 10, StoodVector is the one I reach for the most. Yeah. And to explain that a little bit more, one of the reasons why std vector is almost always the right choice is because of performance. A std vector gives you a contiguous block of memory. And in particular on, you know, sort of our modern contemporary hardware, that locality is almost always going to beat out any theoretical advantages that another data structure might have. You know, there are weaknesses to std vector. You know, it has to, every now and then, it has to go and do these reallocations to grow. You have to have a good growing algorithm. It can sometimes, because of that growing algorithm, it sometimes can be memory inefficient.
if you will, because of the iterators. So we almost have like 100 operating on 10, and of those 10, StoodVector is the one I reach for the most. Yeah. And to explain that a little bit more, one of the reasons why std vector is almost always the right choice is because of performance. A std vector gives you a contiguous block of memory. And in particular on, you know, sort of our modern contemporary hardware, that locality is almost always going to beat out any theoretical advantages that another data structure might have. You know, there are weaknesses to std vector. You know, it has to, every now and then, it has to go and do these reallocations to grow. You have to have a good growing algorithm. It can sometimes, because of that growing algorithm, it sometimes can be memory inefficient.|||如果你愿意这么说的话，正是因为有了迭代器。所以我们几乎是“100个函数操作10个数据结构”，在这10个数据结构中，`std::vector`是我用得最多的。是的。为了进一步解释这一点，`std::vector`几乎总是正确选择的原因之一就是性能。`std::vector`为你提供了一块连续的内存区域。特别是在我们的现代硬件上，这种局部性（locality）几乎总是能胜过其他数据结构可能拥有的任何理论优势。你知道的，`std::vector`也有缺点。你知道的，它每隔一段时间就必须进行重新分配（reallocation）来扩容。你必须有一个好的扩容算法。有时由于这个扩容算法，它在内存效率上可能会有所欠缺。
And like doing insertion in the middle is obviously, you know, not a very cheap operation, but you might go and look at using a different data structure that might be better at some of these things like stood list, which is, or a doubly linked list. You might think, okay, well, you know, I know I need to do a bunch of insertions in the middle or insertions at the front. So I'll use list in this algorithm instead of vector because I'm anticipating that. But with a doubly linked list, you're doing pointer chasing, right? All the memory is disjoint. And so because of that, you're paying this regular penalty of you're not walking through memory contiguously,
And like doing insertion in the middle is obviously, you know, not a very cheap operation, but you might go and look at using a different data structure that might be better at some of these things like stood list, which is, or a doubly linked list. You might think, okay, well, you know, I know I need to do a bunch of insertions in the middle or insertions at the front. So I'll use list in this algorithm instead of vector because I'm anticipating that. But with a doubly linked list, you're doing pointer chasing, right? All the memory is disjoint. And so because of that, you're paying this regular penalty of you're not walking through memory contiguously,|||比如在中间进行插入显然……你知道的，这不是一个很便宜的操作。但你可能会去看一看其他在这些方面表现更好的数据结构，比如`std::list`，也就是双向链表。你可能会想：“好吧，我知道我需要在中间或头部做一堆插入操作。所以我会在这个算法里用`list`代替`vector`，因为我预料到了这一点。”但对于双向链表，你在进行指针追逐（pointer chasing），对吧？所有内存都是不连续的。正因为如此，你必须付出无法连续遍历内存的常规代价……
which is what modern hardware is meant to do. And so, yes, you might get this benefit with the doubly linked list when you're, you know, inserting an element in the middle, but you're paying this penalty in every memory access and in the memory access pattern itself. And so that often, that overhead of that less efficient memory access pattern often makes it a wash or makes using the list slower. So sort of unintuitively, there are some cases where the things that a vector is bad at, it would be better than the competition solely because it has this nice property that it's contiguous. And it being contiguous means it's easier for it to be cached and it's easier for it to be prefetched. If you look at modern
which is what modern hardware is meant to do. And so, yes, you might get this benefit with the doubly linked list when you're, you know, inserting an element in the middle, but you're paying this penalty in every memory access and in the memory access pattern itself. And so that often, that overhead of that less efficient memory access pattern often makes it a wash or makes using the list slower. So sort of unintuitively, there are some cases where the things that a vector is bad at, it would be better than the competition solely because it has this nice property that it's contiguous. And it being contiguous means it's easier for it to be cached and it's easier for it to be prefetched. If you look at modern|||而这正是现代硬件擅长的事情。所以，是的，当你使用双向链表在中间插入一个元素时，你可能会获得这个好处，但你在每次内存访问以及内存访问模式本身上都在付出代价。因此，这种效率较低的内存访问模式带来的开销，往往会抵消掉这些好处，或者使得使用`list`变得更慢。所以，有些出乎意料的是，在某些情况下，尽管`vector`不擅长某些事，但仅凭它具备内存连续这一优秀特性，它的表现就会优于竞争对手。内存连续意味着它更容易被缓存（cached），也更容易被预取（prefetched）。如果你看看现代的……
CPUs, they have special hardware that's designed for streaming through memory. That if you're in a loop and you're accessing an array of memory contiguously, there's like special hardware that's designed to figure out, hey, we're in a loop and we're sequentially accessing this contiguous range of memory. So like we should prefetch and cache accordingly.
CPUs, they have special hardware that's designed for streaming through memory. That if you're in a loop and you're accessing an array of memory contiguously, there's like special hardware that's designed to figure out, hey, we're in a loop and we're sequentially accessing this contiguous range of memory. So like we should prefetch and cache accordingly.|||CPU，它们拥有专为内存流式传输而设计的特殊硬件。如果你在一个循环中连续访问一块内存数组，就会有专门的硬件来识别：嘿，我们正在循环中，并且正在顺序访问这片连续的内存范围。所以我们应该进行相应的预取和缓存。
And so, yeah, so that's why oftentimes the sort of naive data structure of vector is the right answer as opposed to something more complex. And it's, I really like that the first thing you mentioned about this idea that, you know, sort of less data structures might be better. That oftentimes you want more algorithms to operate on less data structures. I think a lot of times people question why doesn't C++'s standard library have a richer set of data structures like some other languages. And I think it's largely about that philosophy, that this idea that you don't necessarily need more complex data structures
And so, yeah, so that's why oftentimes the sort of naive data structure of vector is the right answer as opposed to something more complex. And it's, I really like that the first thing you mentioned about this idea that, you know, sort of less data structures might be better. That oftentimes you want more algorithms to operate on less data structures. I think a lot of times people question why doesn't C++'s standard library have a richer set of data structures like some other languages. And I think it's largely about that philosophy, that this idea that you don't necessarily need more complex data structures|||所以，是的，这就是为什么比起更复杂的结构，像`vector`这样看似朴素的数据结构往往才是正确的答案。而且，我非常喜欢你提到的第一点，即……你知道的，更少的数据结构可能更好。通常你希望用更多的算法去操作更少的数据结构。我认为很多时候人们会质疑，为什么C++标准库不像其他某些语言那样拥有更丰富的数据结构？我想这很大程度上是出于这种设计哲学，即你并不一定需要更复杂的数据结构……
and that those tend to be very specialized for particular use cases. Instead, what you need is a core set of really solid data structures and then a set of composable algorithms that build on top of them. One of the key things about the design of the C++ standard library is separation of concerns. For data structures in particular, with the exception of std string, we don't have these big classes that have a billion different algorithms as member functions. Instead, we have fairly simple data structures that expose abstractions like iterators and ranges. And then we have a separate set of algorithms that consume iterators and ranges. Yeah, so there's a bunch of things I want to comment on. So the first one where you were talking about pointer chasing, that ties in perfectly to the talk that I mentioned by Bjorn Fahler, in that one of the very first things in
and that those tend to be very specialized for particular use cases. Instead, what you need is a core set of really solid data structures and then a set of composable algorithms that build on top of them. One of the key things about the design of the C++ standard library is separation of concerns. For data structures in particular, with the exception of std string, we don't have these big classes that have a billion different algorithms as member functions. Instead, we have fairly simple data structures that expose abstractions like iterators and ranges. And then we have a separate set of algorithms that consume iterators and ranges. Yeah, so there's a bunch of things I want to comment on. So the first one where you were talking about pointer chasing, that ties in perfectly to the talk that I mentioned by Bjorn Fahler, in that one of the very first things in|||并且这些复杂的数据结构往往高度专门化，只适用于特定的用例。相反，你真正需要的是一组核心的、非常扎实的数据结构，以及一套构建在其之上的可组合算法。C++标准库设计的关键点之一就是关注点分离（separation of concerns）。特别是对于数据结构而言，除了`std::string`之外，我们没有那种包含无数个不同算法作为成员函数的庞大类。相反，我们拥有相当简单的数据结构，它们暴露出诸如迭代器和范围（ranges）之类的抽象。然后我们有一套独立的算法来消费迭代器和范围。是的，所以有几件事我想评论一下。首先，你刚才谈到指针追逐时，这与我提到的比约恩·法勒的演讲完美契合，因为在他的演讲中，最开始提到的事情之一就是……
his talk that he mentions is that he didn't really have a notion of, you know, the difference between data structures and pointer chasing and like ones that have, you know, contiguous memory and others that don't. And he said that like a good rule of thumb, you know, this isn't always true, but just like his mental model that he has is whenever you are chasing a pointer, you can basically consider that a cache miss, which exactly ties into what you're thinking. It leads to this counterintuitive, well, like, oh, I'm reaching for a data structure that has constant insertion time, which brings me to the second thing.
his talk that he mentions is that he didn't really have a notion of, you know, the difference between data structures and pointer chasing and like ones that have, you know, contiguous memory and others that don't. And he said that like a good rule of thumb, you know, this isn't always true, but just like his mental model that he has is whenever you are chasing a pointer, you can basically consider that a cache miss, which exactly ties into what you're thinking. It leads to this counterintuitive, well, like, oh, I'm reaching for a data structure that has constant insertion time, which brings me to the second thing.|||在他的演讲中，他提到自己过去对……你知道的，数据结构与指针追逐之间的区别，以及内存连续与不连续的区别并没有真正的概念。他说过一个很好的经验法则——虽然这并不总是对的，但作为他的心理模型——每当你在追逐一个指针时，你基本上都可以认为那是一次缓存未命中（cache miss），这与你的想法不谋而合。这导致了一个反直觉的现象，那就是：“哦，我要去找一个具有常数插入时间的数据结构”，这就引出了我的第二点。
I said a std vector has amortized constant insertion. I should have been more specific in saying that. Specifically, that's referring to pushback, the method pushback that inserts at the end of the array. An insertion into the middle is going to have linear time complexity. But that ties in exactly to what you said is that it leads to this counterintuitive, well, I'm reaching for a data structure that supposedly has constant insertion versus linear insertion for a std vector. But due to the cache miss, it's going to erode at some of the, you know, quote unquote, complexity gain that you're getting from switching to a data structure that doesn't have, you know, contiguous memory like a std vector. And yeah, well, and, you know, part of that is, is we spent, I think, a lot of people and a lot of traditional literature spends a lot of time looking at time complexity
I said a std vector has amortized constant insertion. I should have been more specific in saying that. Specifically, that's referring to pushback, the method pushback that inserts at the end of the array. An insertion into the middle is going to have linear time complexity. But that ties in exactly to what you said is that it leads to this counterintuitive, well, I'm reaching for a data structure that supposedly has constant insertion versus linear insertion for a std vector. But due to the cache miss, it's going to erode at some of the, you know, quote unquote, complexity gain that you're getting from switching to a data structure that doesn't have, you know, contiguous memory like a std vector. And yeah, well, and, you know, part of is, is we spent, I think, a lot of people and a lot of traditional literature spends a lot of time looking at time complexity|||我刚才说过`std::vector`具有分摊常数插入时间。我应该说得更具体一点。具体来说，这是指`pushback`，也就是在数组末尾插入元素的`pushback`方法。在中间进行插入将具有线性时间复杂度。但这恰恰印证了你所说的：这导致了一个反直觉的结果，即我去找了一个据称具有常数插入时间的数据结构，而`std::vector`的插入则是线性的。但由于缓存未命中的存在，它会侵蚀掉你从“切换到没有像`std::vector`那样连续内存的数据结构”中所获得的、所谓的复杂度收益。而且，是的，呃……你知道的，部分原因在于，我认为许多人和许多传统文献花大量时间在研究时间复杂度上……
of algorithms, right? Whereas in practice, you do need to think about what the constants are. You know, okay, you know, this thing has O1 insertion, but what is the constant? You know, like, what is that, the actual constant latency? Or, okay, this thing has linear, you know, like, what is that, the actual constant latency? Or, okay, this thing has linear, you know, insertion in the middle, but if I only have 100 elements, how expensive actually is that? And when you start looking at those constants, that's when you see, oh, I only have 100 elements. Insertion in the middle is just going to be cheap for me if this thing is always going to be like that size.
of algorithms, right? Whereas in practice, you do need to think about what the constants are. You know, okay, you know, this thing has O1 insertion, but what is the constant? You know, like, what is that, the actual constant latency? Or, okay, this thing has linear, you know, like, what is that, the actual constant latency? Or, okay, this thing has linear, you know, insertion in the middle, but if I only have 100 elements, how expensive actually is that? And when you start looking at those constants, that's when you see, oh, I only have 100 elements. Insertion in the middle is just going to be cheap for me if this thing is always going to be like that size.|||的算法，对吧？然而在实践中，你确实需要思考常数因子（constants）是什么。你知道的，好吧，你知道这个东西有 $O(1)$ 的插入时间，但常数是多少？你知道的，比如，实际的常数延迟是多少？或者，好吧，这个东西在中间有线性的插入，但如果我只有100个元素，这实际上有多昂贵？当你开始关注这些常数因子时，你就会发现：“哦，我只有100个元素。如果这个东西的大小一直保持在这个量级，在中间插入对我和便宜没两样。”
So, and whereas using the list, all of the operations are going to have this greater overhead so i may as well just use the vector and like sure it's it's linear insertion here but in some cases that's fine yeah that's a it's that's a fantastic point and it applies not just to um uh data structures it also applies to algorithms like. I think it was a couple months ago, a coworker had came and asked me, I'm trying to do a binary search, but I need to look at two elements at a time. My immediate thought was adjacent find, but that's not a binary search. And then I said, I followed up and I said, the binary search equivalent of that is partition point. But then my next question was, do we really need a binary search here? Like, do you know, on average, how many elements is going to be in the list or that you're searching
So, and whereas using the list, all of the operations are going to have this greater overhead so i may as well just use the vector and like sure it's it's linear insertion here but in some cases that's fine yeah that's a it's that's a fantastic point and it applies not just to um uh data structures it also applies to algorithms like. I think it was a couple months ago, a coworker had came and asked me, I'm trying to do a binary search, but I need to look at two elements at a time. My immediate thought was adjacent find, but that's not a binary search. And then I said, I followed up and I said, the binary search equivalent of that is partition point. But then my next question was, do we really need a binary search here? Like, do you know, on average, how many elements is going to be in the list or that you're searching|||因此，既然使用链表（list）所有的操作都会产生更大的开销，那我不如直接使用`vector`。就像——当然，这里是线性插入，但在某些情况下这完全没问题。是的，这是一个非常棒的观点，它不仅适用于呃……数据结构，也适用于算法。我想就在几个月前，有个同事来问我：“我想做一个二分查找，但我需要同时检查两个元素。”我的第一反应是`adjacent_find`，但那并不是二分查找。然后我说，接着补充道，二分查找的等价做法是`partition_point`。但我的下一个问题是：“我们在这里真的需要二分查找吗？比如，你知道平均会有多少个元素在列表中，或者在你要搜索的……”
over, or vector that you're searching over? Because I, you have to profile, I've heard a rule of thumb is that if you have less than 80 elements, a linear time algorithm is going to be faster than a binary search algorithm. I don't know where I heard that. rule of thumb is that if you have less than 80 elements, a linear time algorithm is going to be faster than a binary search algorithm. I don't know where I heard that or if that's true. You know, profile, you know, before you're making these claims. But his response was, oh, it's less than 10. In which case I said, yeah, like we don't need a binary search for that. Just use a JSON find and call it a day.
over, or vector that you're searching over? Because I, you have to profile, I've heard a rule of thumb is that if you have less than 80 elements, a linear time algorithm is going to be faster than a binary search algorithm. I don't know where I heard that. rule of thumb is that if you have less than 80 elements, a linear time algorithm is going to be faster than a binary search algorithm. I don't know where I heard that or if that's true. You know, profile, you know, before you're making these claims. But his response was, oh, it's less than 10. In which case I said, yeah, like we don't need a binary search for that. Just use a JSON find and call it a day.|||你要搜索的`vector`中吗？因为我……你必须进行性能剖析（profile）。我听说过一个经验法则：如果你的元素少于80个，线性时间算法会比二分查找算法更快。我不知道这是从哪听说的。经验法则是，如果元素少于80个，线性时间算法会比二分查找算法更快。我不知道我是在哪听到这个的，也不知道这是否属实。你知道的，在做这些断言之前，先做个性能分析。但他的回答是：“哦，少于10个。”在这种情况下我说：“是的，那我们根本不需要二分查找。直接用`adjacent_find`然后收工就行了。”
So, yeah, it's like thinking like like you said, you know, in academia, you always drop the constants or the coefficients. But in real world, those constants matter. And profiling is very important. So it's funny that you said std vector because when we talked about algorithms, we both, we said, oh, we thought that both of our answers was going to be transform reduce. But then it turned out that, in fact, that wasn't both of our answers for what our favorite algorithms were. And for this, I sort of figured that both of us would, our initial gut reaction would be Stood vector or a a dynamically dynamic array would be our first choice. And it was for you. But I actually am going to argue that there's that that it's not mine and that a dynamic array is often is often too heavyweight.
So, yeah, it's like thinking like like you said, you know, in academia, you always drop the constants or the coefficients. But in real world, those constants matter. And profiling is very important. So it's funny that you said std vector because when we talked about algorithms, we both, we said, oh, we thought that both of our answers was going to be transform reduce. But then it turned out that, in fact, that wasn't both of our answers for what our favorite algorithms were. And for this, I sort of figured that both of our answers, our initial gut reaction would be Stood vector or a a dynamically dynamic array would be our first choice. And it was for you. But I actually am going to argue that there's that that it's not mine and that a dynamic array is often is often too heavyweight.|||所以，是的，这就如同……就像你说的，在学术界，你总是会忽略常数或系数。但在现实世界中，这些常数至关重要。而且性能分析非常重要。所以很有意思的是，你提到了`std::vector`，因为当我们讨论算法时，我们两个人都曾说过，噢，我们以为我们俩的答案都会是`transform_reduce`。但结果证明，事实上那并不是我们俩关于自己最喜欢算法的共同答案。对于这个（数据结构），我原本琢磨着我们两人的最初直觉反应都会是`std::vector`或者动态数组会是我们的首选。对你来说确实如此。但我实际上要说的是，这并不是我的首选，而且动态数组通常……通常过于沉重了。
And I actually think that you're going to agree with me. I don't think that a dynamic array like std vector is your favorite algorithm. I think you've just been tricked into thinking that because the actual container that you need the most frequently doesn't exist in an easily accessible form in C++. So let's talk about how we use a dynamic array. So one of the key properties of a dynamic array like std vector is that it's growable. That is that after I've created it, I need to add more elements to it. But I think in a lot of cases, we know ahead of time how many elements we're going to put into that vector. And there is a pattern that is very common that I see a lot. I call it like the default construct and reserve pattern
And I actually think that you're going to agree with me. I don't think that a dynamic array like std vector is your favorite algorithm. I think you've just been tricked into thinking that because the actual container that you need the most frequently doesn't exist in an easily accessible form in C++. So let's talk about how we use a dynamic array. So one of the key properties of a dynamic array like std vector is that it's growable. That is that after I've created it, I need to add more elements to it. But I think in a lot of cases, we know ahead of time how many elements we're going to put into that vector. And there is a pattern that is very common that I see a lot. I call it like the default construct and reserve pattern|||而且我其实觉得你会同意我的看法。我不认为像`std::vector`这样的动态数组是你最喜欢的算法（注：此处主播口误，原意应为数据结构）。我觉得你只是被忽悠成这么想的，因为你在C++中最频繁需要的实际容器，根本没有以一种容易获取的形式存在于语言中。所以我们来谈谈我们是如何使用动态数组的。动态数组（如`std::vector`）的关键属性之一就是它是可增长的。也就是说，在我创建它之后，我需要往里面添加更多元素。但我认为在许多情况下，我们提前就知道要往这个`vector`里放多少个元素。有一种非常常见、我经常看到的模式。我称之为“默认构造并预留容量（default construct and reserve）”模式……
when you're using a vector where you will default construct the vector, and then you'll immediately call reserve on it with the capacity that you need. And for those who may not be aware, when we talk about capacity, that's different from size. So capacity is how many slots for elements does the vector or the dynamic array have. And size is how many slots are currently in use. And every time the size grows above the capacity, you have to reallocate the entire vector storage and move everything into the new capacity. So typically capacity is grown with, you know, some internal algorithm, like you double capacity every time so that you don't have
when you're using a vector where you will default construct the vector, and then you'll immediately call reserve on it with the capacity that you need. And for those who may not be aware, when we talk about capacity, that's different from size. So capacity is how many slots for elements does the vector or the dynamic array have. And size is how many slots are currently in use. And every time the size grows above the capacity, you have to reallocate the entire vector storage and move everything into the new capacity. So typically capacity is grown with, you know, some internal algorithm, like you double capacity every time so that you don't have|||当你使用`vector`时，你会先对`vector`进行默认构造，然后立即以你需要的容量（capacity）调用`reserve`。对于可能不太了解的人来说，当我们谈论容量时，它与大小（size）是不同的。容量是指`vector`或动态数组拥有多少个用于存放元素的槽位。而大小是指当前正在使用多少个槽位。每当大小增长超过容量时，你就必须重新分配整个`vector`的存储空间，并将所有东西移动到新的容量空间中。所以通常容量的增长是通过……你知道的，某种内部算法来实现的，比如每次将容量翻倍，这样你就不用……
to constantly be reallocating. But so let me just ask you, Connor, how many times have you constructed a std vector and then like either immediately called reserve or immediately called resize and then never added never increased the capacity after that uh probably more times than i can count although i will say as a small caveat to this i've discovered a new pattern using thrust fancy iterators which also exist in boost as boost iterators, where you can set up like transform iterators and then just call the range constructor and avoid like the resize or the reserve, which I think is a super nice pattern. Because then you can also declare your data structure container const by using those fancy iterators. But that's only been recent in the last couple of months that I've discovered that pattern. And before that, yeah, probably more times than I can count.
to constantly be reallocating. But so let me just ask you, Connor, how many times have you constructed a std vector and then like either immediately called reserve or immediately called resize and then never added never increased the capacity after that uh probably more times than i can count although i will say as a small caveat to this i've discovered a new pattern using thrust fancy iterators which also exist in boost as boost iterators, where you can set up like transform iterators and then just call the range constructor and avoid like the resize or the reserve, which I think is a super nice pattern. Because then you can also declare your data structure container const by using those fancy iterators. But that's only been recent in the last couple of months that I've discovered that pattern. And before that, yeah, probably more times than I can count.|||经常不断地重新分配了。不过，让我问你个问题，康纳，你曾有多少次构造了一个`std::vector`，然后要么立即调用`reserve`，要么立即调用`resize`，在那之后却再也没有添加、再也没有增加过容量？呃，可能多得数不清了。不过我要作为一个小小的免责声明补充一点：我最近发现了一种使用Thrust花哨迭代器（fancy iterators）的新模式——它们在Boost中也作为Boost迭代器存在——在那里你可以设置诸如变换迭代器（transform iterators）的东西，然后直接调用范围构造函数（range constructor），从而避免了`resize`或`reserve`，我觉得这是一个超级棒的模式。因为这样你还可以通过使用那些花哨的迭代器将你的数据结构容器声明为`const`。但这只是我最近几个月才发现的模式。在此之前，是的，可能多得数不清了。
Yeah. And so this sort of gets to one of the defects that std vector has in C++, which is there is not a good way. One, there's not a simple way with std vector to reserve on construction. There is no constructor that lets you reserve capacity without also allocating elements. So you can construct a vector with an initial set of elements, but then you have to pay to initialize those elements. So like if I'm creating a one gigabyte vector of doubles, I could just call the vector constructor that says I want in elements that have this initial value.
Yeah. And so this sort of gets to one of the defects that std vector has in C++, which is there is not a good way. One, there's not a simple way with std vector to reserve on construction. There is no constructor that lets you reserve capacity without also allocating elements. So you can construct a vector with an initial set of elements, but then you have to pay to initialize those elements. So like if I'm creating a one gigabyte vector of doubles, I could just call the vector constructor that says I want in elements that have this initial value.|||是的。这就触及了`std::vector`在C++中的缺陷之一，那就是没有一个好的方法。第一，使用`std::vector`时，没有一种简单的方法可以在构造时进行预留（reserve）。没有任何构造函数允许你在预留容量的同时不同时分配元素。所以你可以用一组初始元素来构造一个`vector`，但随后你必须为初始化这些元素付出代价。比如，如果我要创建一个大小为1GB的`double`类型的`vector`，我只能调用那个声称“我想要n个具有此初始值的元素”的`vector`构造函数。
But then I'd have to pay the cost of initializing that whole gigabyte of memory with this initial value when all I really wanted to do was just reserve that storage, and then later I was going to push back into the vector. And that's why you have this common pattern of default construct it, and then you call reserve. And there's also the case where you want to get uninitialized elements. And there's actually a C++ committee proposal regarding this. For example, let's say you've got like a std string and you want to call a C library function that's going to initialize the constants of that std string.
But then I'd have to pay the cost of initializing that whole gigabyte of memory with this initial value when all I really wanted to do was just reserve that storage, and then later I was going to push back into the vector. And that's why you have this common pattern of default construct it, and then you call reserve. And there's also the case where you want to get uninitialized elements. And there's actually a C++ committee proposal regarding this. For example, let's say you've got like a std string and you want to call a C library function that's going to initialize the constants of that std string.|||但接着我就得付出用这个初始值去初始化整整1GB内存的代价，而我真正想做的事情仅仅是预留那片存储空间，然后稍后再往`vector`里压入元素。这就是为什么会出现这种常见模式：先默认构造它，然后调用`reserve`。还有一种情况是，你想要获取未初始化的元素。实际上C++委员会有关于这方面的提案。例如，假设你有一个`std::string`，你想调用一个C库函数来初始化该`std::string`的内容。
Well, there's not really a good way to do that. The only thing you can do is you can resize the string, which then zero initializes all the characters. And then you can call that library function or you can copy into it from some external API. And that's a little bit unfortunate. And so there's this proposal P1072 that tries to address this for originally for std vector and std string, but now just for std string.
Well, there's not really a good way to do that. The only thing you can do is you can resize the string, which then zero initializes all the characters. And then you can call that library function or you can copy into it from some external API. And that's a little bit unfortunate. And so there's this proposal P1072 that tries to address this for originally for std vector and std string, but now just for std string.|||嗯，其实没有什么好方法能做到这一点。你唯一能做的就是调整字符串的大小（`resize`），这会将所有字符初始化为零。然后你才可以调用那个库函数，或者从某个外部API将数据复制到其中。这有点令人遗憾。因此，有一个名为P1072的提案试图解决这个问题，它最初是针对`std::vector`和`std::string`的，但现在仅针对`std::string`。
But it is a slightly hazardous pattern where you want to say, oh yeah, I want to like add elements to this container, but I don't want them to be initialized. Like that's how you get, that's how you lead yourself towards, you know, memory safety violations and all sorts of unpleasant, uninitialized variable hazards. But if you really care about performance, it can matter. So I'm going to argue that dynamic array is, in many cases, more than we need because in many cases, we know what the capacity is going to need to be up front and it's never going to change. And so what we really need is we need a container that's just a C++ equivalent of, you know, a C style array where I want to allocate it, I want to give
But it is a slightly hazardous pattern where you want to say, oh yeah, I want to like add elements to this container, but I don't want them to be initialized. Like that's how you get, that's how you lead yourself towards, you know, memory safety violations and all sorts of unpleasant, uninitialized variable hazards. But if you really care about performance, it can matter. So I'm going to argue that dynamic array is, in many cases, more than we need because in many cases, we know what the capacity is going to need to be up front and it's never going to change. And so what we really need is we need a container that's just a C++ equivalent of, you know, a C style array where I want to allocate it, I want to give|||但这是一种略带危险的模式，你想表达的是：“哦，是的，我想往这个容器里添加元素，但我不想让它们被初始化。”这正是你如何让自己走向……你知道的，内存安全违规以及各种令人头疼的未初始化变量隐患的方式。但如果你真的关心性能，这确实很重要。所以我认为，在许多情况下，动态数组超出了我们的实际需求，因为在很多情况下，我们提前就知道容量需要多大，而且它永远不会改变。所以我们真正需要的是一个容器，它只是C++版本的、类似C风格数组的东西——我想要分配它，我想要赋予它……
it a size, and I want to have control over whether and how those elements get initialized. Now there are a few options in the C++ standard library if you want this data structure. So if you know a compile time, the size, you can use stdarray, which is a compile time sized array with more or less the same interface as vector. Of course, it can't be resized, etc. But I think the more common pattern is that I just want a runtime-sized array. And there's no specific class for this in C++, but you can express this with unique pointers array specialization. Are you familiar with Unique Pointer's array specialization? Walk us through it. So Unique Pointer in C++ is an RAI type that owns some pointer that you, programmer have allocated and it has a customizable deleter parameter which is used to clean up this pointer that you've given it when the unique pointer is destroyed.
it a size, and I want to have control over whether and how those elements get initialized. Now there are a few options in the C++ standard library if you want this data structure. So if you know a compile time, the size, you can use stdarray, which is a compile time sized array with more or less the same interface as vector. Of course, it can't be resized, etc. But I think the more common pattern is that I just want a runtime-sized array. And there's no specific class for this in C++, but you can express this with unique pointers array specialization. Are you familiar with Unique Pointer's array specialization? Walk us through it. So Unique Pointer in C++ is an RAI type that owns some pointer that you, programmer have allocated and it has a customizable deleter parameter which is used to clean up this pointer that you've given it when the unique pointer is destroyed.|||一个大小，并且我希望能够控制这些元素是否以及如何被初始化。如果你想要这种数据结构，C++标准库中有几个选择。如果你在编译时就知道了大小，你可以使用`std::array`，它是一个编译时大小固定的数组，其接口与`vector`大同小异。当然，它不能调整大小等。但我认为更常见的模式是我只想要一个运行时大小的数组。C++中没有针对此事的特定类，但你可以用`unique_ptr`的数组特化（array specialization）来表达这一点。你熟悉`unique_ptr`的数组特化吗？给我们讲解一下。因此，C++中的`unique_ptr`是一种RAII类型，它拥有某个由你（程序员）分配的指针，并且它具有可定制的删除器（deleter）参数，当`unique_ptr`被销毁时，该删除器用于清理你交给它的这个指针。
And it's called unique pointer because it is uniquely owning. Only that unique pointer can have access to it. You can't copy the unique pointer. You can move the unique pointer, though. And so this gives us some guarantees about, you know, who has access to this pointer. And in particular, because it's uniquely owned, you don't have to worry about who's going to clean it up.
And it's called unique pointer because it is uniquely owning. Only that unique pointer can have access to it. You can't copy the unique pointer. You can move the unique pointer, though. And so this gives us some guarantees about, you know, who has access to this pointer. And in particular, because it's uniquely owned, you don't have to worry about who's going to clean it up.|||它被称为`unique_ptr`是因为它是独占拥有的（uniquely owning）。只有那个`unique_ptr`才能访问它。你不能复制`unique_ptr`。不过你可以移动`unique_ptr`。因此，这为我们提供了一些关于……你知道的，谁拥有该指针访问权限的保证。特别是，由于它是独占拥有的，你不必担心谁来清理它。
The answer is always going to be there's just one person that there's just one instance of this unique pointer. And that's the one that's going to clean it up. So you don't have to do reference counting or anything like that. But unique pointer is usually used for managing the lifetime of like a single pointer. But there's this specialization where if you write like unique pointer, template brackets, yeah, Chevron, and then like int empty braces, square braces, that will give you this specialization that is intended for arrays. And it will have an array access operator. And by default, it will use an array delete. And so this is a pretty nice way to proxy or to implement just a container that is just,
The answer is always going to be there's just one person that there's just one instance of this unique pointer. And that's the one that's going to clean it up. So you don't have to do reference counting or anything like that. But unique pointer is usually used for managing the lifetime of like a single pointer. But there's this specialization where if you write like unique pointer, template brackets, yeah, Chevron, and then like int empty braces, square braces, that will give you this specialization that is intended for arrays. And it will have an array access operator. And by default, it will use an array delete. And so this is a pretty nice way to proxy or to implement just a container that is just,|||答案永远是：只有一个实体，即这个`unique_ptr`的唯一实例。就是它来负责清理。所以你不需要做引用计数或类似的事情。但`unique_ptr`通常用于管理单个指针的生命周期。不过存在这样一种特化：如果你写出像`unique_ptr`，模板尖括号，然后是`int`，方括号，那就会得到专为数组设计的特化版本。它将拥有一个数组访问操作符。并且默认情况下，它会使用数组的`delete`。所以这是一种相当不错的代理或实现方式，用来实现一个简单的容器，其功能纯粹是……
I want to allocate this array that has n elements and that number of elements is never going to change. And it's also useful because you fully control the allocation of these elements. All that you do is you give a pointer to unique pointer. It doesn't create the pointer itself. So you can control how you allocate that memory, how you initialize it. So you don't have to worry about this case of, oh, well, I want to use a std string, but I want to control how these elements get initialized and created.
I want to allocate this array that has n elements and that number of elements is never going to change. And it's also useful because you fully control the allocation of these elements. All that you do is you give a pointer to unique pointer. It doesn't create the pointer itself. So you can control how you allocate that memory, how you initialize it. So you don't have to worry about this case of, oh, well, I want to use a std string, but I want to control how these elements get initialized and created.|||我想分配一个包含n个元素的数组，并且这个元素的数量永远不会改变。它也很有用，因为你可以完全控制这些元素的分配。你要做的全部事情就是把一个指针交给`unique_ptr`。它自己不会创建这个指针。所以你可以控制如何分配该内存、如何初始化它。因此，你无需担心诸如“噢，我想用`std::string`，但我希望控制这些元素如何被初始化和创建”这种烦恼。
With UniquePointer, you have full control. All that it provides you is the safety of the resource acquisition is initialization pattern, where when the unique pointer goes out of scope, you know that it's going to clean up the memory using the deleter. So that's, I think, something that I reach for very frequently. And there's a related facility called allocate unique that's proposed been proposed for the past two c++ standards but hasn't been very high priority um uh and that just gives you a convenience for saying hey i have this c++ allocator and i want to create a unique pointer that uh uses this allocator to allocate and deallocate the memory. Interesting.
With UniquePointer, you have full control. All that it provides you is the safety of the resource acquisition is initialization pattern, where when the unique pointer goes out of scope, you know that it's going to clean up the memory using the deleter. So that's, I think, something that I reach for very frequently. And there's a related facility called allocate unique that's proposed been proposed for the past two c++ standards but hasn't been very high priority um uh and that just gives you a convenience for saying hey i have this c++ allocator and i want to create a unique pointer that uh uses this allocator to allocate and deallocate the memory. Interesting.|||使用`unique_ptr`，你拥有完全的控制权。它为你提供的全部价值，就是RAII（资源获取即初始化）模式的安全性——当`unique_ptr`超出作用域时，你知道它会使用删除器自动清理内存。所以这我认为是我非常经常会去使用的一个东西。还有一个相关的工具叫做`allocate_unique`，它在过去的两个C++标准中都被提出过，但优先级一直不高，呃……这只是提供了一种便利，让你能够说：“嘿，我有这个C++分配器（allocator），我想创建一个使用该分配器来分配和释放内存的`unique_ptr`。”真有意思。
If we want to point our listeners at more resources on this pattern, what would you recommend? So we'll put a link in the show notes to the allocate unique paper. In our thrust library, we have an implementation of allocate unique, and then we have a few different overloads. We have one for, you know, arrays, and I use it all the time. Like, that's my go-to thing. The paper is P0316. And it's, it's, it doesn't seem like it's a particularly important thing. But I think if you start, I think if you start thinking about all the places where you can use a unique pointer,
如果我们想为听众提供更多关于这个模式的资源，你会推荐什么？因此我们会在节目简介中放一个指向 allocate_unique 提案的链接。在我们的 thrust 库中，我们有一个 allocate_unique 的实现，然后我们有几个不同的重载。我们有一个针对数组的，而且我经常使用它。就像，那是我的首选。这篇提案是 P0316。而且它，它看起来似乎并不是一个特别重要的东西。但我想如果你开始，我想如果你开始考虑所有可以使用 unique_ptr 的地方，
the array version, instead of a std vector, you'd be surprised how commonly this comes up. Yeah, it sounds like a common pattern that potentially a lot of people just aren't reaching for because it's not, you know, stated right next to std array and std vector in sort of the containers, docs, slash blogs that are written. Well, and it's not perfect because like it doesn't give you iterators, et cetera.
数组版本，用来替代 std::vector，你会惊讶于这种情况有多么常见。是的，听起来这是一个常见的模式，可能很多人没有去使用它，因为它并没有，你知道的，紧挨着 std::array 和 std::vector 列在容器的文档或博客里。嗯，而且它并不完美，因为它没有提供迭代器等等。
Like we could build a version of this. And at one point in C++'s history, we sort of did. There was this thing called DynArray that we tried to do, but it ended poorly. That was before my time. I don't remember all of the details, but we could do a better job here. Yeah, it sounds like an interesting direction
就像我们可以构建这个版本的一个变体。而在 C++ 历史上的某个时期，我们实际上做过类似的事情。曾有一个叫做 DynArray 的东西是我们尝试过的，但结果很糟糕。那是很久以前的事了。我不记得所有的细节了，但我们在这方面可以做得更好。是的，这听起来是一个有趣的方向
for the future of C++ once we get everything that's supposed to go into 23 and the bleed over into 26. That, you know, this could be a future proposal for C++. Yeah. What's the thing that you're most will and will not be in C++23, but assuming that everything that's being quote-unquote targeted by individuals for C++23, I'm most excited about seeing the extension to the range of stuff. On top of that, I think pattern matching is going to be awesome. Executors, you know, everything that's going in, honestly, like library support for coroutines,
关于 C++ 的未来，一旦我们把所有应该进入 C++23 的东西以及溢出到 C++26 的东西都搞定。那个，你知道的，这可能会成为 C++ 的未来提案。是的。对你来说，最希望和最不希望在 C++23 中出现的是什么，但假设所有个人针对 C++23 的提案都能实现，我最兴奋的是看到 ranges 相关扩展。除此之外，我认为模式匹配会非常棒。执行器，你知道的，所有将要加入的东西，老实说，比如对协程的库支持，
I think that's going to open up the world of coroutines to a lot more people. But yeah, at the top of the list, it's definitely the range of stuff. How about yourself? That's hard to say. I would probably say I'd probably say executors, but I also think that things like allocate unique and any invocable, which is a better version of std function. I think those are going to have a lot of impact on people's day-to-day lives so i think that that those will be uh those will be big wins too all righty i think we're once again past our 30 minute uh target time but uh it's all right is that our target time? yeah well you know
我认为这会向更多人敞开协程的世界。不过是的，在清单的最顶部，绝对是 ranges 相关的东西。你自己呢？这很难说。我可能会说，我可能会说是执行器，但我也认为像 allocate_unique 和 any_invocable（它是 std::function 的更好版本）这样的东西。我认为这些将对人们的日常生活产生很大影响，所以我认为这些也将是重大的胜利。好了，我想我们再次超过了我们 30 分钟的目标时间，不过没关系。那是我们的目标时间吗？是的，你知道的
20, 25, 30 minutes it's never a hard limit though it's our podcast we get to do what we want and I think we're going to have to do another one next week because there's a whole other set of data structures that at least I want to talk about
20、25、30分钟，不过这从来都不是一个硬性限制，这是我们的播客，我们想做什么就做什么，我想我们下周还得录一期，因为还有一整套数据结构，至少是我想讨论的
and yeah so maybe we'll do part two next week. Sounds like a plan. All right. Awesome. Thanks, everyone, for listening, and we'll catch you guys in the next one. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以也许我们下周会做第二部分。听起来不错。好的。太棒了，谢谢大家的收听，我们下期节目再见。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。